[Music]
[Applause]
dominique wilkins
he is the hall of famer hawks vice
president basketball
operations special adviser to the
atlanta hawks and a hawks analyst
he was courtside there had his trey
young jersey on last night
nick how you doing today i'm doing good
how are you doing i'm doing okay
uh so you had a courtside seat with uh
giannis going down what did you think
when uh when you saw that
well even before he went down the hawks
was playing great basketball and uh
i thought that the group was on the
floor had
milwaukee all out of sync where they
couldn't really
you know shake the hawks and
redisplay very well well and i agree
that even if the greek freak
did not get injured i thought the hawks
felt like like it meant more there was a
sense of
urgency for them it almost felt like the
buck showed up and realized trey young
wasn't playing
and it didn't really click that you know
what you got to win these games did you
did you get a sense that the hawks
understood hey
we have to be you know we pick up our
intensity even more because we don't
have trey young
well yeah you know and they knew that
this was
really the biblical game for them now
because you know you lose this game
going back to milwaukee
you're down 3-1 and so you know i
thought that
the hawks came together of the unit they
had man this team has a lot of grit
you know and i think that's the
difference man they there's no quit
there's
they always have to fight in them and so
um
they just came together as a unit and
that's how they won this game
i mean it was a well-balanced game for
the hawks
you expect trey young back for game five
well yeah i think right now you kind of
playing with house money a little bit
too even though
you know the milwaukee has the home
court back
the hawks are playing with a lot of
emotion they're playing with a lot of
confidence right now
and so they've shown that that you know
trey has help
from his teammates that can get the job
done now do they want trade back of
course they do
um but again they're showing
the ability to to win when your
superstar goes down but do you expect
him to play
i always expect to trade the play i
really do i mean the guy loves to play
the game of basketball
so yeah i look for him to be back
how would he have done playing when you
played
well you know you know it's two
different areas you know he'd have been
he'd have been a great players as
there's no question i'll tell you what i
love to play with i mean
i probably got the easiest 35 40 points
of my career if i played with him the
way
he passes the ball um you know
he's just one of those players that come
around every once in a while
that has that it factor i mean
man he's got it do you ever hit your
head on the rim during a game
many times
many times yeah yeah oh yeah oh yeah
you know i played the game with reckless
abandon i played it you know above the
rim
and especially early in my career um
you know there's a lot of guys back in
here who played that way you know so
yeah
yeah i'm gonna guess uh dr j probably
hit his head on the room a few times oh
yeah i've seen him
you know dude i had i saw him do it in
the uh
slam dunk contest where he hit his head
on the in the backboard coming down
you know so yeah but do you believe that
somebody could actually
if i put a quarter on the top of a
backboard nick
do you think that there's somebody who's
played who could have
jumped to the top of the backboard and
brought a quarter down
well i don't know you know you know we
heard that over time but yeah there has
been
a few guys who could go to the top of
the backboard
now it takes a lot of time to go up
there and grab something and
put something else up there but there
there have been guys who
went to the top no question well like
david thompson to me was one of the
the the great leapers that i ever saw
but you had you know these uh playground
legends who
uh you know people always bring up could
you get to the top of the backboard
i mean yeah i mean you know i you know
i've been to the
above this square you know many times
and
you know you used to play around with it
when you're young and see who could jump
the highest and
i've always had great leap and ability
you know
and one of the you know the the
longest jumping or i should say vertical
leads in the history of the game so i've
been up there with you know
some of the best of them but you know
you talk about david thompson
you talk about earl manigault you talk
about so many guys
that man i mean dave thompson was
incredible i mean i saw him
put the ball uh this cuff it
in his arm and punch it through the
basket in practice
you know when i was in high school i
went to watch one at practice because
you couldn't dunk in
the games back then in college and
man he was something else talking to
dominic wilkins the
hall of famer hawks vice president of
basketball operations
the the load management now though nick
and minutes played and the injuries
is there is there a reasoning behind all
of this i thought with load management
limiting the minutes that that would
reduce the injuries
well back when we were playing you know
if you if you didn't play
uh especially you know in big games
you know you kind of lose something you
know you don't have that same rhythm you
know
you don't have that same chemistry
because you know you know you're trying
to get yourself back in courtship you're
trying to get that rhythm back
and when you set out games you know for
me i felt like i lost something
but you know it's a different time now
you know it's different reasoning for
you know what they do and you know and
some
a lot of times it works and sometimes it
doesn't yeah i just wonder
that you know they're going to be
talking about let's just
how about the regular season 68 games
let's say
but it feels like they're going to load
manage even at 68 games
and so does it matter really what the
number is if they reduce the regular
season games in the nba
well i'm like this this is what we
signed up for
as as young players coming up to junior
high school high school and college
we signed up for this you know and i
think you know when you continue
to change the game yeah i think you lose
a little something
and so you know we signed up to to to
play a game that we love and
you know you deal with the consequences
you know you know
when you you get injured and you get
hurt i mean this part of it
it just happens that's in any sport yeah
it just feels like that
you can get into another contract you
know that that it's about extending your
career which i understand that but these
owners are probably saying hey look
we got to get paid here too you want to
reduce the regular season
schedule how about we reduce some of the
pay that we give you
i don't think any players are going to
sign up for that nick when you're caught
between a
rock and a hard place you know you know
if you give up something
you got to give something you know yeah
so
i don't i don't see it going to 68 games
i think it's crazy
really to be honest with you because you
talk about taking a big chunk of games
away
you know i don't know if you know
again i would have played many many
seasons i played 82 games
so i never thought twice about it if uh
the hawks advance do you think atlanta
would want the sons of the clippers
i don't think it really matters i don't
think it really matters because the way
we're playing and the confidence we're
playing with
the chemistry we have right now it
doesn't matter who you play the thing is
just getting there and once you get
there
anything can happen
uh great to talk to you nick and uh good
luck with game five coming up tomorrow
night we appreciate your time as always
thank you man i appreciate it dominique
wilkins hall of famer